I'm standing here with Ross Rebagliati.
Ross is a gold medal skiboarder.
And Ross, you claim you can teach me
to master the board today.
Not a problem, Conan, we're gonna do it.
I don't like speed.
(audience laughing)
And I don't like to fall.
I'm not a big fan of snow
or cold weather.
(audience laughing)
Snowboarding's your sport, Conan.
You think so?
Absolutely.
You're very positive, I like that.
I have a custom board.
My nickname is The Cone-Dog.
(audience laughing)
Okay, that's sweet.
For Conan, see how that works?
Oh yeah, right,
yeah.
You,
Good one.
And then look at this guy down here.
That's me.
Aww!
I put the little teeth in,
(audience clapping)
and I'm wearing a scarf 'cause it's cold.
And I don't know why
I'm wearing a nightcap.
(audience laughing)
I just, I'm kinda mad
at the guy who did this 'cause I wanted it
to be more ski wear, and it looks like
I'm going to sleep.
(audience laughing)
[Ross] I like your ears.
What's, like that, that bunny
ears on the top, what that?
Oh, right up here?
Yeah,
what's those?
Yeah, he's the dog.
That's the Cone-Dog.
That's the dog part,
okay, I see.
Yeah.
We got the canine's-
Cone-Dog.
And the ears, I see.
And then to intimidate my
opponents, check this out.
You're gonna love this.
When I go for the big jump.
Nice.
Look at that, when I go way up
into the air.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
"You suck," right in the guy's face.
Then I grab the clip and
I show him my ass pad,
and then right down.
(audience laughing)
When you're learning to initiate a turn,
you kind of want to kind of
like slide your back foot around
like this, right?
Right.
That creates-
So the back foot
is the rudder sort of.
Kind of like a rudder.
Yes.
So it kinda
tilts your board that way.
(audience laughing)
You don't want to knock
the boards down the hill.
But I just knocked your board downhill.
You want to keep your knees flexible.
Flexible.
You don't want to be stiff.
You want to be able to absorb everything.
Right.
All right.
You gotta be kinda loose.
Loose.
Right, okay.
Okay, hands in front.
All right.
Hands in front,
you know you kinda-
And it's kind of
a Zen thing, right, like-
Yeah, right, surfing.
It's very much I am one with
what's happening around me
and anything that happens is okay.
Whatever happens is cool,
'cause that's-
Exactly.
Just the way it is, dude,
that's just the way it is.
Right.
(audience laughing)
(Conan grunting)
(boot clicking)
Son of a bitch!
(boot thudding)
(audience laughing)
(Ross chuckling)
(Conan exhaling heavily)
I don't know what happened there,
I totally lost my cool.
(audience chuckling)
Gonna strap on.
I think my straps
are in the way, there, okay.
Now I'm in.
I'm not gonna get on my
knees in front of you, Conan.
[Conan] Whatever, you've heard the rumor.
This one first,
(audience laughing)
goes underneath there.
I am strapped in, clocked
up, and dialed out.
Let's chop.
(Conan grunting)
Ah, watch this!
Ah, ah!
(board sliding)
(audience laughing)
Ah! (grunts)
(board sliding)
Ah, don't help me, I can do it.
Ah!
(board thudding)
Son of a bitch!
(audience laughing)
(board sliding and thudding)
Ah, (grunting) dah!
Ow!
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
Can I get some paramedics over here?
I think that, I think that went very well.
(audience laughing)
Stand up slow, nice and easy.
Yeah, oh yeah!
Get a feel.
Yeah.
Okay.
(board slams)
What we're gonna do is we're
gonna go in that direction
and then I'm gonna get
you to do the rudder thing
with that foot.
(Conan exhales)
And turn around.
Take it kind of behind you
and we're gonna make a turn this way.
Okay.
All right?
That's definitely not gonna happen.
(audience laughing)
(board sliding)
There we go, look at that!
[Ross] You're doing good, keep, yeah,
you're doing good.
There's on the heel.
Ah! (grunts)
(body slams)
(audience laughing)
Now that's my stop.
That's how I stop.
That's just my technique.
I don't even want to call it
falling, I want to call that
my dismount.
(audience laughing)
So right here, the next section
where you're gonna try it
from going to the heels
to turn onto your toes.
I'm going to make an
example demonstration.
(board sliding)
Heel side, heels back, rudder!
(audience laughing)
Yeah, there's no way.
(branch snapping)
Ah! (grunts)
Yeah, ah! (grunts)
I think there's a bear in here.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, come back
if you can.
Ah! (grunts)
(audience laughing)
Okay, here, sit on your butt if you can.
There we go!
Let's just lie here for awhile.
(audience laughing)
That's fine.
You know, I can work with that.
Hey, Ross?
Yeah.
Do you ever wonder, like,
(audience laughing)
if it was the end of the universe,
but then what's after that,
do you know what I mean?
I just keep coming and coming.
I never give up until it
starts to get difficult,
and then I usually quit.
(audience laughing)
Ross?
Conan.
I love you.
(audience laughing)
Let's get back out there.
All right, let's do it.
(Conan grunting)
50/50.
Loosey goosey leaning back,
edging back into hill.
(upbeat rock music)
(audience laughing)
Who do you think you are?
God?
You think you're God?
(sobbing)
I can't, God! (sobs)
Okay, I'm better.
(audience laughing)
Let's go.
(upbeat rock music)
Now you're all toes now.
Now I'm toes, baby!
(audience laughing)
This is the more natural
position for a snowboarder to be in.
Why didn't we start on that then?
(audience laughing)
I just thought, you know, you're kind of
half-ass backwards all the time
that I'd just go with the flow.
[Audience Member] Oh, ho, ho, ho!
Don't make me dial you up, dude.
(audience laughing)
'Cause this a number you don't want
to be connected to.
(audience laughing)
(board sliding)
Good job.
Hey, look!
I stopped
(audience cheering)
without falling down, by god!
(board sliding)
[Ross] Heels, heels!
Heels!
(audience cheering)
Lookin' good!
(audience applauding)
This mountain is my lady.
(audience laughing)
You're my lady.
Conan, I've been watching you,
I think you're ready for the pipe.
Dude, I know I'm ready for the pipe.
You ready, Conan?
(upbeat rock music)
Let's do it.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)